some people who don't get the stakes
here are the five remaining never Trump
errs in America yeah there are that many
there used to be a lot of never Trump
errs now there are like two people left
in a basement somewhere they've come out
with an ad called morning in America and
it just shows they don't get what's
going on
there's morning in America today more
than 60,000 Americans have died from a
deadly virus Donald Trump ignored with
the economy in shambles more than 26
million Americans are out of work the
worst economy in decades
Trump bailed out Wall Street but not
Main Street this afternoon millions of
Americans will apply for unemployment
and with their savings run out many are
giving up hope
millions worry that a loved one won't
survive kovat 19
there's morning in America and under the
leadership of Donald Trump our country's
weaker and sicker and poorer and now
Americans are asking if we have another
four years like this will there even be
an
paid for by the Lincoln project which is
responsible for the content of this
advertising morning in America you get
it mo you are and ing
you get it it's really it's really
clever huh because it's like them in the
1980s and 84 Reagan had an ad called
morning in America with the sunshine and
they're doing morning in America you get
it you get it it's a pun never mind that
how offensive this ad is and the idea of
the upside down American flag really
that's an inappropriate use of that
image not that these guys know anything
about what's appropriate or reverent but
it's also just so lame what a lame ad I
mean it's first of all it's made for TV
which has been dead for ten years now
second of all it's this stale imagery
and the and the deep booming voice on
the voice over Donald Trump is bad
that's right this ad paid for by people
against Donald Trump he's bad it's just
like so lame make a meme or something
man you know this is 2020 already it
shows us that obviously they don't get
it the this group of people are all well
president Trump can tell you himself he
his words not mine they're a bunch of
losers
I saw a project they they called the
Lincoln project and I would have them
change the name to the loser's project
because if you take a look at [ __ ] it's
this George Conway the guy is Kellyanne
must have done a big number or
George Conway and some other people
Weaver every one of them I either
defeated or or they lost by themselves
but it's a group of major losses they're
Republican losses and if they would
really think about it
I have 252 beautiful brand-new
conservative wonderful judges two
Supreme Court judges that are great we
produced the greatest economy in history
until a month and a half ago when we got
hit by the virus and we hadn't closed it
down and we'll do it again we've rebuilt
our military we've done things that
nobody has been able to do I've gotten
the greatest tax cuts in history in the
history of our country the biggest tax
cuts the Democrats want to raise you in
taxes
I got regulation cuts the biggest in the
history of our country no matter how
long a president serve with all of that
I guess they don't like me but let me
just tell you these are losers from day
one yes so you know president Trump
doesn't mince words here they have lost
a lot of campaigns I mean they lost
campaigns for John McCain for John
Kasich for Mitt Romney for the right
they're just they're not the varsity
squad when it comes to political
consultants so they've missed the time
they've missed the shift they're also
missing what's happening in politics
right now and that is my big fear I fear
that people are missing what's going on
I think I think a lot of people are
waking up the ones who understood what
the Trump election meant even if you
don't love Trump even if you don't like
the way he talks what it meant that you
had this guy who had kind of different
policy prescriptions who kind of talked
a little differently acted a little
differently vanquished the house of
Clinton shook things up the fact that
that guy won really meant something that
we've moved into a new kind of politics
or we're moving in that direction now
there is a fundamental transformation
that is underway or that the left wants
there to be underway and we can either
go along with it wake up one day and
realize we lost our whole country and
our whole culture or we can push back I
as you might have noticed suggest the
latter
[Music]